on this episode I talk about negative
reviews that are anonymous the butt and
the climb
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 79 of the askgaryvee
show thanks for being on with me meerkat
what's up yeah I don't know a lot to say
actually you know I really just don't I
think we should just get into the show
and focus on growing a beard the Jo how
do I have nothing to say Darrelle Revis
has come home nothing is more exciting
to not only get back one of the great
jet players of all time while he still
could have some really solid years in
him but to take them from the dreaded
hated awful disgusting war stabber New
England Patriots has been just a
tremendous tremendous feeling and I'm
very happy about it
Doral welcome home Theresa asks what is
your butt and how do you get off what's
the biggest button you hear from others
that's holding them back
Theresa the amount of butts that I hear
is actually stunningly overwhelming you
know I pride myself in not being a butt
guy and so I think I think that i think
that the butts that I hear all the time
I didn't have any money I didn't have a
chance I grew up in a poor neighborhood
I didn't have a mentor I didn't get the
lucky break
people are loaded with butts it's why
the majority of people fit into the
standard of one's life right whatever
those ambitions may be I I think that
for me my butt is usually but I love the
process I love the climb when I don't
achieve the maximum upside in my career
it's going to be predicated on the fact
that I hedged about loving the process
and so within the context of finances I
didn't buy the Jets because but you know
is really that whole thing is because oh
I liked the grind too much and that
didn't allow me to scale and create the
level of wealth I needed to be able to
actually pull it off
that's my narrative and so that's my but
but I love the process the amount of
butts I hear though are just everything
and really there you
what but is is it's an excuse and now
look before I finish with my Rara
scenario let's very much understand
there's real stuff going on in the world
I mean you may be born in a part of the
world where there's you know a dictator
or communism or Justin or you know do I
think that it's as easy to be an a
female entrepreneur in the Middle East
as it is to be in New York City no I do
not do I think it's you know do I think
that it's harder for somebody that's
born in Mississippi a non-white male in
America as it is for somebody that that
is born in an L a white male to succeed
I do but on the flip side let me flip it
I think the hustle and the grind of
coming from the grind has a big
advantage I see a ton of people some
people think you're dead on impact
because you're born a minority or or you
know or or in a bad spot or to a
drug-infested home that you are you're
predisposed to losing ironically in my
weird twisted brain in the game that I
play the hustle game the but the real
climb like it's almost equally
predicated on your spirit and your gusto
as it is on your skill set I think a lot
of people that are born into Kush are in
a setback situation because it's going
to come so easy and you know so I just
think it's how you optically look at the
world but I will tell you this I hate
excuses man I hate him with all my heart
I really take enormous pride and I mean
it I just had a we had a hard core where
I got a had a hard core mean I don't
know if any of you were here vaynermedia
meeting on Friday where I talked about
stuff and and I'm always scared and I
don't know the team believed me when I
said hey look before I start this is my
fault but I really mean it
I take pride in taking blame it's crazy
you know xx this Jets Patriot thing I
see all these Pat fans making fun of me
right yesterday and I feel sad for them
that they've won four Super Bowls I like
the climb and the grime and and they're
trying to win it right and that's kind
of how I think about butts and blames
and excuses I take pride and I like
taking the blame and
my whole company in saying this is my
fault even though I know there's so many
other people that are at fault as well
I'll take that on me and so you know
butts are bad but they're not as obvious
as I think some people may think Robert
asks is there value in using social to
engage with customers even if they're
not in your market and will never buy
from you Robert this is a great great
great great question because riding the
hashtag I write a blog post about that
thing you know and all that stuff but
your questions the right question which
is what's the ROI of jumping in so the
Apple watch comes out and everybody's
talking about it what's the ROI you know
Twinkie putting a Twinkie on their wrist
and saying yeah this is our version of
it or or riding a trend and putting out
content of what everybody's talking
about whether it's that new technology a
new app meerkat a new celebrity you know
whatever it is if they are not likely to
buy from you look I think I think the
value is very low and I think that that
may throw somebody for a loop but the
truth is the one upside is the homerun
the anomaly which is you get somebody
because they care about that trending
topic and they amplify you which then
brings people awareness to your high-end
shoe store or purses or your fifty
thousand dollar pieces of art so as
people have become the infrastructure of
media distribution riding the
conversation of what people care about
with the hope that they create the
retweet the reblog the share that then
creates the amplification of awareness
to somebody who is connected to them
does have some Hail Mary some rogue
longtail upside but speaking to and
communicating with people who are not
going to buy your product no matter what
does not have enormous ROI never did in
the old world has a little bit more now
because they have the opportunity to
share it and become bring awareness to
people who may buy but it is absolutely
limited and it's a tactic that needs
strong strategy around it
Brendan asks I'm biking across Canada
pencils of promise and documenting my
daily videos on YouTube
what other jabs could I use so that I'm
not just right hooking for donations hey
Bren you know as a proud board member of
pencils of promise I want to thank you
personally for your adventures
you know the jab content-wise obviously
even this little question had a great
content beautiful views India was really
taken aback and so let's just show India
being taken aback and so that was
amazing uh and so uh and so you know the
the jab that I'm looking for from you is
you're in the mindset of you know you
didn't take this biking adventure for
kicks and giggles obviously the charity
component is in you but it's not the
only thing people always do things that
are selfish to them at some level so you
want to create video content and
document that maybe you're a documentary
thing you know you're using this great
thing you're doing as a global jab to
maybe bring you awareness to an
opportunity in the future I want you to
take a step back because I think you can
do all the jabbing right right put out
good content on Instagram and snapchat
and Facebook and different native you
know the book Jab Jab Jab right hook and
respect the platforms put out good
content the one thing that I think is
missing from a lot of people's
repertoires when they're in this world
is the listening the Bionic ears of what
Twitter searches if I were you the other
jab you can do at scale is to go into
Twitter search and search people who are
talking about pencils of promise and
then jumping into their conversation and
not jumping in and saying cool that you
raised money like oh I raised forty
eight dollars for pencils of promise in
my school book fair fourth grader tweets
right or the mom of the fourth grader
you don't jump in and say cool I'm doing
this watch this that's too much of a
right hook you jab within the listening
oh I like that your jab
within the listening and so what you do
is you jump in there and say that is
phenomenal and just by you interacting
with that person right they're gonna
maybe look at your profile and then
they'll see your latest three or four
tweets were around this content and now
you've really double jabbed into the
funnel of that donation right you jab
within the listening you jabbed with the
content that became the Gateway to the
donation or whatever you're trying to
achieve the awareness so a shitload more
Twitter searching
think would be a tremendous opportunity
as a matter of fact this is an enormous
opportunity to do a humble brag so do
you reckon gonna have to do some editing
for this episode because I want you to
really take over the screen and maybe
use some music maybe non hip-hop music
and so what you can do is take over the
screen for 10 or 11 seconds so when
people really really absorb this very
proud moment of mind which is some some
data has just come out of who has spoken
in the social sphere to the most
individual people and you can see I'm
enormous ly proud papa of my execution
of being number one and Steve I don't
know if you saw let's show Steven his
reaction to this not only was I number
one we're double number two I mean it
was like then do you saw the data right
like dismantled well I think as an
effect number two three and four
combined probably get close to my number
I'm very proud of this and I think it
speaks to the advice I'm giving you here
so it was funding answer your question
but I was maybe even more fun to humble
brag that I'm number one and I'm
actually talking to people and that's
why there's ROI Nicole asks how do you
deal with reviews that could impact your
business
Nicole is a great question one of the
reasons I had always been a big push
against cup guy I don't know what that
means
why I was a loud advocate in the other
direction of things of Yelp and other
things of that nature was they were
anonymous reviews and I knew of PR
agencies that were getting paid to leave
negative reviews of their competitors
stuff which is why I was always a big
fan of Facebook and Facebook Connect
real identity there's two things to
understand one I do think anonymous
reviews and an honest review sites are
losing their equity I do think that
Steve and an India and all of you
watching and everybody at meerkat what's
up you know I love doing that
take anonymous reviews with a grain of
salt right like that's changed like from
2004 compared to now you just take them
with a grain of salt because we become
cynical to knowing people do it on
purpose the big thing that I think you
should do when somebody you're right we
live in this crappy world where you guys
are serving at a restaurant I'm Yogi's
and restaurants cuz they feel or an
airline airlines are doing things so
right annika like they're flying planes
machines in the air I'm crossing the
world at scale landing at the proper
times leaving at the proper times
keeping us safe they've given us Wi-Fi
in there it's cozy there these are big
machines feel like flying through the
air and if it's like eight minute delay
you're like [ __ ] you Delta I mean it's
crazy it's crazy talk anyway so you're
right you know we don't get the credit
for the good we get dismantled for the
bad right like the athletes that are
doing wrong things all over the place
all the ones that are doing charitable
things and great things nobody wants to
cover that it's just unfortunately the
way it is now huh did it I did a my boy
a time get a rare Davies may gonna come
back and that makes me happy I can't
wait to see what he did make sure you
email me that moment because I don't
watch the show
I think that you should jump into any
yelp review or any Foursquare review or
any review any negative review that you
have to jump in and answer every one of
them immediately hey
salty pants 49 call me here's the number
I'm super upset I don't understand I
remember you you know
don't fight it you know fighting it is
feeding the wrong energy you're a
business this is their opinion they
could be wrong but you need to at least
have one more level of empathy and
listening before you get into the fight
of it so the way you can handle it is by
jumping monitoring it and jumping into
all of them because the optics of you
jumping in to the rest of the world is
actually more powerful in the
amplification of who and what your
intent is and the depth of actually
giving a crap about that one person
really really matters hey Gary here's my
question when will social marketing
spending be bigger than television
commercials Fred great question first of
all if you guys don't know who Fred
Wilson is then you know nothing about
the start-up VC community in New York or
the world one of the great VC's of all
time Fred I don't like you for that I
like you because you're a Jets fan
without rivas can you believe it so Fred
great question I appreciate you asking
it know my gut answer and I'm gonna use
social as current digital platforms let
me explain why my answer to that
question is somewhere in the ballpark of
35 25 22 years long and by then I don't
think we're gonna be calling them social
networks we're gonna evolve to whatever
they are but digital is eating up a lot
of TV but the web's been around for 20
years the consumer web since 95 in
banners and email and Google AdWords
they're still not making an enormous
dent against television now we've got
over the top i my prediction is 22 years
because all these things take longer I
also think advertising in general is
gonna change if the money's gonna go
into content and it's all going to be
native
interwoven much more but but you know
I'm not sure if I'm right about the year
twenty twenty twenty two years out
twenty thirty seven but what I will tell
you is this Fred that the TV commercial
industry is in the early stages of
looking very similar to the late years
of the newspaper advertising world
it was Craigslist that really was a very
important kind of watershed moment to
the death of newspaper advertising and I
believe that it is Netflix that is the
same to the TV commercial world because
as everything starts going over the top
and people don't want to consume
commercials and really could even say
DVRs right TiVo probably was the first
precursor to it but we're well on our
way but you know question of the day how
many people in this room actually watch
television commercials and I don't mean
in this room I mean the people that are
watching
I mean meerkat give it to me right now
everybody's watching when they want to
how they want outside of live TV shows
which are you basically you know live
result shows you know award shows and
sports it guys without sports the TV
industry would be in such a different
different different place I ask my
question of the day I really enjoyed my
mood here it was a very kind of like
interesting mood it's an interesting
mood episode 79 80 coming up only 20
more shows before we hit 100 you keep
asking questions I will keep answering
them